you're lost stuck at home moving your
way through a degree you know doesn't
matter and you're just looking for some
extra ways to make cash online in this
video I'll be going over four of the
best ways you can make anywhere from a
few extra thousand up to $20,000 a month
starting with literally 0 short form
content is without a doubt the best
route you could go down as a beginner
everyone at the top understands this
what's your relationship right now with
short form content I mean it's a
no-brainer you should be doing it with
that let's get into business idea number
one Tik Tok creativity program faceless
accounts everyone always wants to know
what the next nft crypto pump wave and
I'm telling you right now this is it Tik
Tok is paying $1,000 per million views
on the creativity program right now
which is literally unheard of we have
never seen a short form content platform
paying that much money per million views
so the only main requirements to get
inside of this program is to be 18 or
older be from one of these countries and
hit 10,000 followers on your Tik Tok
account which I know might sound a
little bit daunting if you've never run
an account up before but I'm telling you
right now it's a lot easier than you
think for example this is one of my
students right here he's hit 60,000
followers in only 3 weeks since starting
his account 3 weeks he started this
account and he's already monetized
making over $100 a day pretty insane and
then the only other thing is when you're
making these videos the only ones that
qualify for this $1,000 per million
views are the videos you post that are
over 1 minute long now you're seeing all
of your favorite content creators
talking about reposting their Clips on
Tik Tok clip my videos put it on Tik Tok
I don't care anybody wants to make money
if you're just watching you C it up post
it on your own platforms and the truth
is they're lying to you the reason that
they're telling you to repost their
clips and whatnot is so that they can
get their face out there more brand
awareness and gain Cloud the problem is
when you repost these Aiden these Kai
sonat Clips all these mainstream guys on
the creativity program you get flagged
for original content and your videos get
demonetized so you're not even able to
actually make make this $1,000 per
million views when you're reposting
these other guys videos so to actually
get your videos monetized there are much
better routes specifically faceless AI
accounts let me show you a few quick
examples all right so we have this
account here called Bikini Bottom news
what they do is they take current events
that are trending they chat gbt a script
and then they use AI to make the rest of
the video so it's the Bikini Bottom guy
to saying the news and then they just
have um pictures popping up on the top
but what this does is a gets around the
original content thing so that all of
his videos can get monetized so for
every video you see on his channel that
has a million 2.7 million views he's
making around $11,000 per million views
on these so printing cash and you can do
the exact same here's two other examples
I'll pop up real quick that are
utilizing AI to get around this original
content stuff and make that bread we
have infohub and joke fella both doing
the same thing just taking stuff that's
already worked on other accounts has
previously gone viral and then just
spinning it in their own way utilizing
AI adding these popups to make that bag
there's literally a bunch of different
routes you can go down to you don't got
to copy any of these accounts you could
talk about old history facts you could
talk about water slides roller coaster
reviews you could talk about content
creators Rises and downfalls there's
literally a million different niches you
can go into it all you do is you chat
gbt the script edit it a little bit so
the hook is a bit stronger maybe add a
little um a couple unique elements that
you would think of yourself that would
get the viewer to rewatch or comment and
then use um AI or just find pictures on
Google and just add those in along with
the captions very simple this will only
take you 1 to two hours a day and can
make you over $10,000 a month this one
strategy alone I actually just made a
free training diving into this method
exactly so I'll leave the link at the
top of the description so you guys can
check that out after the video anyways
let's get into the next method organic
Ecom you always hear all these Ecom
gurus talking about their $7 pre-built
Shopify store knowledge however the best
way to start a business is to get cash
in not throw out a bunch of money and
then just hope it works out the typical
e-commerce business model is you find
your supplier connect your website run
up ads upcharge and make cash organic
Ecom is pretty much the same way except
you don't need to invest all that money
into running and testing ads what you do
is you post short form videos on Tik Tok
reels and shorts driving people to your
e-commerce store that way you're able to
get all these millions of views of
traffic totally for free not having to
spend tens of thousands of dollars
paying Tik Tok in China for their
ad money there's plenty of
accounts making absolute bread off of
this right now with literally a$ Z
budget organic e-com is definitely
something I would recommend you guys to
get into especially right now with the
Tik Tok shop so even if you don't want
to actually have to build the product
and everything yourself you could find a
product on the Tik Tok shop that you can
do affiliate marketing for and in the
Tik Tok shop it'll tell you what
different percentages there are how much
money you would be making off of the
different products and then from there
you can just go about making your videos
and then linking the product in and then
when you link the product you can just
add like a call to action in pointing an
arrow to the bottom left of the screen
where that Tik Tok um shop button is and
then lead those purchases there and the
Tik Tok Shop features great because it's
a lot less friction so rather than
people having to go to your linkoln bio
go on the site wait for that to load
enter their card info on the Tik Tok
Shop people go and they can literally
buy with Apple pay so it's a lot more
seamless and the conversions are a lot
higher
so once you find your product whether
you're pushing something to an actual
store you built or something in a Tik
Tok shop you're testing all these
different organic videos then once you
have one pop off you get some cash in
the door then you can reinvest it into
ads because you could just reuse that
same video that worked on organic got
you millions of views you then use that
as an ad because you know that that
already works better so then you can
just use that same operation to scale up
your ads rather than initially you would
have just been dumping thousands
of dollars into different ad creatives
and praying it works organic eccom is
the much better route cash in reinvest
not cash out business idea number three
a short form marketing agency I get
dozens of DMS every single day about
this however nobody's doing it right
thankfully you have me so I'm going to
give you guys the free sauce right now
and what you need to do for those of you
who don't know what this is a short form
marketing agency is basically where you
find people already making content
business owners successful entrepreneurs
people looking to get into content and
you offer to blow them up on Tik Tok
reals and shorts the mistake that
everyone makes is they write three
paragraphs send it to me talking
about a whole life story all this
how they can do short form for me how
good the videos will be all this
nonsense and I don't even end up reading
it all cuz it's just not worth my time
when I get so many of these DMS every
day so what you're going to do when
reaching out to clients which is way
better than all these other clowns is
you're going to show them results so
previous accounts you've run that have
worked well you're going to send a quick
concise message only a couple sent
sentences organized nicely and then
you're going to edit them a free sample
that way they can see what your editing
style looks like with their videos I
know this might take a little bit more
time but the time it takes to do this
for the clients is going to lead you to
getting a lot more people then once you
have one to two good clients under your
belt you do a good job for them blow
them up on Tik Tok then you can just
give them like a 10% referral fee for
finding you other clients and from there
you don't even need to do any more
Outreach it'll just be a word of mouth
thing and pretty soon you'll be over 10K
a month now when you actually are
running the agency there's a bunch of
different ways you could go about it you
could Outsource the editing to people
below you and manage and train them you
can do it all yourself to have the
highest margins I'm not going to talk
about that too much but the base premise
is you collect the content from the
client you edit and posted for them to
take that off their plate and just get
them a bunch of views like I said if
you're new to short form and lost still
make sure you check out that free
training that I'll leave at the top of
the description it'll help you out a lot
more give you some more knowledge on how
to actually get started business number
four growing your personal brand this is
by far the most important one that every
single one of you should be doing I
started the sunny Faz brand only one
year ago and in this time I've Had The
Taste reacting to me on live stream have
you heard of the Bas mother I've become
really good friends with sneo I have
girls reaching out to me I've moved to
Miami made hundreds of thousands of
dollars off of this brand alone met
loads of millionaires hanging out with
DV seals tons of tons of different crazy
going on all because I've started
my personal Brin brand and decided to
stick a camera on my face there were
literally unlimited benefits to building
up a personal brand money status women
your network becomes a lot easier to
build up people want to work with you
for free just to be around you so many
different benefits but here's what
you're probably thinking I don't know
what the I should be posting I've
never started a brand or put a camera on
my face before or if I have it never
worked out quick answer to that issue
look at your social media feeds and see
what's working for other people is doing
well for them and then just do that in
your own own way with your own unique
spin on it so if you want to start
making motivational videos talking about
how you got through mental health
episode and how to be more disciplined
you could look at one of these bigger
creators that's doing it see what
they're doing that's working well for
them whether it's a specific hook do
they have a cool background behind them
whatever it is and then just do what
they're doing with your own unique spin
on it because what they're doing is
they're testing it for you they're
trying different things out to see what
works well and then you're just stealing
basically what does well for them and
you're doing it better in your own way
I've done this tons of different times
so for example when I started this
YouTube channel I analyzed who's the
other best mom reacts Channel on YouTube
it was cuff boys so I stole his titles
if you look at our titles it's the mom
and then the reacts and all capital if
you look at my video descriptions at the
time I copy and pasted vid IQs did those
in my own way the thumbnails were sneo
style like I you you analyze what other
people are doing well you pluck
something and then you do it in your own
unique way so it's not completely copy
and pasting but it's taking inspiration
and running with it so like even when I
was still doing the mom reacts videos to
find videos to react to I would look at
like Ben Shapiro daily wire this kinds
of stuff see what recent videos they
reacted to what went most viral for them
and then I would just react to those
same things so that way they're doing
the testing they're reacting to a bunch
of different videos then I can just see
what did better what didn't do well for
them and if something didn't do well I
know okay no point in reacting to that
on my channel and if something did well
okay obviously I should react to that if
it did well for them it'll probably do
well for me but I'm giving it my own
unique spin on it it's still me reacting
to it I just took inspiration from what
did well so you're literally just going
to pick a niche or something you're
somewhat passionate about can be
absolutely anything analyze what
someone's doing well and you're going to
get started right away the beautiful
thing about this is not only will
building up your brand bringing all
those other benefits I talked about
earlier but you can also do those other
side hustles I talked about earlier at
the same time as building up your brand
that's what I recommend all of you do
now You' obviously noticed how every
single business idea that I talked about
has been based around short form content
and that's for a reason I'm telling you
right now this is the future people's
attention spans are only going to keep
getting worse and worse and with that
short form content is only going to keep
getting bigger and bigger so you have to
learn this skill now and be able to
capitalize off of it as much as possible
in the next few years before the US
dollar the Great British pound
everything goes to zero and we're all
this is the time where you need
to be monetized offing this I don't know
how a lot of you guys are able to sleep
at night I'm being dead serious right
now when you're not making a lot of
money like realistically like I
I struggle to sleep at night right now
it literally makes me nervous that I'm
not making $500,000 a month
myself because I know what's coming in
the future lockdowns are going to return
don't cancel me I would never kill
myself but yeah start learning these
skills right now make as much money as
possible like I said if you want access
to that free training so you have more
info on how you can get started right
away that link is going to be at the top
of the description so go check that out
drop a like if you like these kinds of
videos I'll see you in the next one
peace